hello and welcome to this video playing
irony 64 we spent all of you narrowly oh
yeah hmm i think since 20 years i'm
training coaching and giving an essence
okay but it's not an active player for a
long time I think I haven't seen him
playing for a long while I was very
strong GM clearly above 2,500 okay so
i'm playing a somewhat funky opening
here which is probably slightly I'm um
yeah maybe a little bit too risky but
we'll see what happens can i play quinta
have six no it's nonsense okay i'm
taking a development is not a
particularly great i'll see i wanted to
try something else not one of my
standard solid openings so okay i cannot
take here because of route to be one yo
you write down castles age for is
somewhat dangerous really it is somewhat
dangerous
yeah it looks a little bit wrong but not
sure what else to do
Yankee cards the B porn ultimately not
sure that he needed to but at one point
you feel like you you probably should
stop relying on a tactic down huh Bishop
one each six is of course extremely
annoying
yeah I can try to play on the current
site just without the King being castle
but this looks some yeah it looks
questionable really
KFC for check here and then see three
things like that
even be should be to as possible group
takes e4 check and then see three how
strange see 3 yeah it's extremely weird
very strange but currently I don't see
why it should not work check
yeah okay so I've won this material but
the rook hangs so i have to go f6 i
guess yeah well Knight f6 theoretically
speaking but I guess f6 back in position
is weak I mean no doubt damn so what's
to watch to do a thermo like okay
Queenie three years playing Bishop b5
okay let's push the pawn
need to use what I have and the a point
is definitely one of the upsides a king
at 79 he has this Bishop g4 move it's
okay it's it's hard to see what what's
this okay yeah I'm on the fr that's
definitely true ah how words what a mess
what a bloody mess time morning wow it's
finding good moose now what are you
doing here stop doing that stop finding
good moves ok I thought I could but I
only have one check there anyway i have
to do it now rook takes rook takes I've
got Quincy one but it's not clear that i
have more than some checks Quincy 121
maybe you can go really all the way to
deform as weird as it looks check 21
Queens your king g for its kind of crazy
but it's maybe maybe possible shoot
shoot ok rookie three check it should be
lost somehow this position
we should before coming yeah wow wow
okay black resigns yeah it was always
tough I mean objectively black is of
course winning after we should be too I
think but maybe winning is strong with
what's the engine saying equal yeah at
one point I'm socially okay here but
it's very difficult without a king
without a kingdom and it was tough to
play for sure b5 this one yeah 5a I can
take any of course i will look dad roxy
seven is strongly better so am i getting
an advantage in this is 9 f8 when the
engine gives me a pretty substantial
plus but this is not easy yeah of course
I overlooked that and this is definitely
losing check I have this check but you
can go to g4 I'm out of I'm out of ideas
now yeah okay maybe the opening is a
little bit too dicey I mean this has
been played by some good players but
it's definitely not my kind of position
yeah check y'all start with this move
but it's probably the same thing
the engine prefers that by the way check
with compensation and check engine
agrees with all this basically yeah it's
very tough I mean I just have to be them
more precise but it's it's not easy to
play with this little time why this why
does he say just has to push forward
okay well thanks for watching